the first clip is from 2019 so this is
after Cabe McCabe has been dismissed
from the FBI and he is on a book tour
and I think it he's having conversation
with Anderson Cooper and I think it
reveals a little bit of his mindset uh
the mindset of the people at the very
top of uh you know uh the investigation
about how they were thinking about this
how this was going to play out so Adam
go ahead and play that clip for us
not just one not just two but numerous
people in and around the president in
and around the campaign maintained
contacts with individuals from Russia
people connected to the Russian
intelligence Services you have a number
who have been charged a number who've
been already convicted and pled guilty
for all kinds of different offenses do
you still believe the president could be
a Russian asset
I think it's possible I think that's why
we started our investigation and I'm
really anxious to see where director
Mueller concludes that
and then this next clip is just from
last week so clearly his you know his
belief that Trump might have been a
Russian asset in early 2019 has not been
borne out whatsoever but uh now he's
being asked on CNN about his reaction to
the Durham report as someone who's named
it hundreds of times let's talk about it
with CNN senior law enforcement analyst
Andy McCabe he's a former deputy
director of the FBI and importantly he
oversaw what became known as a crossfire
hurricane probe into Trump in 2016. John
Durham says that you shouldn't have
launched it what's your response
John Durham is wrong and it's not just
me that says that every other entity
that's investigated our in our
activities in 2016 agrees and that's of
course as you mentioned uh the doj uh
Inspector General Michael Horowitz as
well as the Senate intelligence
committee LED of course at the time by a
republican uh uh so this is
this report poppy stands as an anomaly
so Eli what's your reaction to now CNN's
uh senior legal analyst Andrew McCabe's
assertion that this is just an outlier
and everyone else says that the
investigation was pretty much Justified
well
you know and now uh let's turn now that
we're talking about the danger to
children right now
um at clown parties let's turn to our
senior analyst John Wayne Gacy
um tell us what do you think about this
new Crackdown on child abuse and are you
serious this is I'm just I I I know I
should I should we know it's there but
like yeah
the intelligence agencies yeah news on
on previous streams it's uh fairly
disturbing but uh putting that aside
okay the substance
um so first of all we should just point
out Andrew McCabe did not elect to talk
to John Durham and yet he is here
talking to CNN so that's what so okay if
you really think you're if you really
think it's all just a big persecution
that's that's a tell second of all he's
wrong it's not anomaly
um Michael horowitz's report in 2019
um is devastating to the FBI
um the FBI itself in response to dorm
reports said
we take it very seriously and we've
already put reforms in place and the
people who are responsible for this no
longer work for us
so I mean I was paraphrasing there but
so so the the FBI itself doesn't think
it's an anomaly
um you know and
I guess the other point is that you know
that first clip he's making that a you
know late February 2019 he's talking to
Anderson Cooper uh we would learn in a
few months
that the Mueller team found no evidence
of a trump Russia conspiracy
and then we would learn by the end of
the year that the FBI had deceived and
gamed the surveillance Court the fisa
court and that um it wasn't an isolated
incident and you know we would learn all
kinds of other things about this
investigation so what the hell is the
former FBI deputy director talking about
when he says he thinks that the
president of the United States might be
a foreign agent which is basically I
mean you are you are that is John Birch
Society level invective
from the other direction and it's coming
from the FBI and there was no evidence
and he knew there was no evidence for it
when he was making those remarks there
were no evidence when he was like when
he was fired from the FBI of that and
the I mean the arrogance and the fact
that it's like you're pouring you're
it's it's a kind of like at some I mean
listen I don't go in for the
disinformation talk that everyone's
talking about
but if you want an example of
disinformation Andrew McCabe in his
interview with Anderson Cooper that's
disinformation and he knew better that's
the thing it's like listen I forgive
other analysts for saying in 2017 it
looks like Trump has something to hide I
thought Trump had something to hide I
when he fired Comey in the way he did
there was a lot of information the
public didn't have
so I mean that's that happens that you
know life you know there's but the
people at the FBI who are who are
running the investigation they have far
more information than us as it should be
so for them to then become like public
pundits or something and then
use that their positions to create a
false kind of Scandal or false crisis in
American democracy it's despicable there
and it's unbelievable to me that he's
still an analyst for CNN how could you
be some how could you be on the the
journalism side of a news Outlet as some
sort of analyzing the news he's he
should be the target of a hostile
interview you know I mean like he should
he should be like you know Jake Tapper
should should do his whole thing by the
way Jake Tapper is very good on the dorm
report I should say
um I want to credit him for that and
there's a lot of you know but you know
when Jake Tapper was saying I made a new
rule we're not going to have any
Republicans on they're gonna lie about
the 2020 election okay great can we have
a rule We're not gonna have anybody
who's gonna lie about the 2017
investigation into Trump including our
our own senior law enforcement analyst
so I I just find it incredible that he's
still an analyst and he's not the only
one I don't want to pick on Andrew
McCabe all of these people it's
particularly true with CNN and really
MSNBC I mean half their roster seems to
be these former yeah
yeah it's uh I I to rebuild their
credibility I really would like to see
an editorial policy go into place that
you just don't hire former Intel
officials to be commentators for you it
doesn't well it seems I should say if if
if he's if you have on just a generic
former senior FBI person as a news
analyst because I don't know we we there
was a terrorist attack or something yeah
I mean that's fine that person is going
to have perspective on how
investigations work is probably going to
have some old contacts
it's when there is this the story is the
is is is the bad behavior from the FBI
you can't then have these people on as
like news analysts hey thanks for
watching that excerpt from our
conversation with Eli Lake dissecting
the Durham report you can watch that
full conversation right here or another
clip from the conversation right here
and tune in every Thursday at 1pm for
more conversations like this